olaf scholz également le chancelier
allemand évolué aux côtés des dirigeants
européens ce sont les dirigeants des
trois pays fondateurs de l'union
européenne qui se déplace aujourd'hui en
ukraine d'où le le symbole renforcer and
my et bonjour notre correspondante à à
berlin and ça fait longtemps que la
folle c'était attendu en ukraine un
dirigeant également très critiquée dans
le pays aujourd'hui
oui olaf scholz sous le feu des
critiques en ukraine est donc sous
pression pour leur premier voyage
officiel à kiev depuis le début de la
guerre il y a quelques jours à peine le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky a
accordé plusieurs entretiens à la presse
allemand dans lesquelles ils
reprochaient une fois de plus au
chancelier allemand de ne pas livrer
assez rapidement les armes promise par
l'allemagne à l'ukraine alors cette
polémique elle fait rage depuis des
semaines déjà car l'allemagne a certes
fourni un certain nombre d'armes légères
à l'ukraine mais à lui a promise
également des armes lourdes et
ultramoderne parmi lesquels un système
de défense anti aérien capable de
protéger les grandes villes du pays
contre des frappes aériennes elle a
promis également l'allemagne des lance
roquettes ainsi que des chars anti
aériens seulement la livraison de ces
armes n'a toujours pas eu lieu notamment
parce qu'il faut former les soldats us
craignant à leur maniement c'est en tout
cas ce qui explique les autorités
allemandes mais en ukraine ses délais de
livraison sont évidemment difficilement
compréhensible et ce matin l'ambassadeur
d'ukraine en allemagne a donc une
nouvelle fois exhorté le chancelier
allemand a accéléré le rythme de ses
livraisons d'armes et notamment des
chars de combat pour que cette visite en
ukraine ne reste pas qu'un symbole il ya
de fortes attentes 1 exprimer côté
ukrainien et en allemagne il y en a t'il
quelles sont-elles aujourd'hui
est bien en allemagne aussi le
chancelier allemand est vivement
critiqué depuis le début de la guerre en
ukraine en raison de ses hésitations et
de ses tergiversations il est critiqué
par l'opposition bien sûr mais aussi par
de nombreux libéraux et des écologistes
qui font partie de seconde de son
gouvernement mais qui sont nettement
plus favorables à un soutien
renforcer à l'ukraine la presse
allemande elle non plus n'est pas tendre
avec le chancelier mais en revanche la
population elles restent très divisés
selon un sondage qui paru cette semaine
la moitié des allemands sont favorables
à des livraisons d'armes lourdes à
l'ukraine mais 43% des allemands
souhaitent que le gouvernement allemand
restent très prudents pour ne pas
provoquer moscou alors vous le savez le
pacifisme a été la marque de fabrique de
la politique étrangère allemande depuis
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
l'allemagne a entretenu également un
partenariat très étroit économique
notamment avec la russie depuis la fin
de la guerre froide et on sent bien
aujourd'hui que cette longue tradition
est encore bien palpable malgré le
changement d'époque promis par le
chancelier olaf scholz après le début de
la guerre en ukraine merci beaucoup a
noyé en direct de